team jackson what's happening team
jackson what's happening team jackson
what's happening team jackson what's
happening again
healed together without hurting each
other my new book is available now at
the link down in the caption
and by the way i'm gonna speak in third
person how a man
treats you is how he feels about you i
just had to co-sign that bro like that's
some of the realest [ __ ] i've ever heard
or if he treats you like you a dummy
that's how he feels about you but you
know i'm tired of seeing y'all settle
for these lames and these scrubs
they treat y'all like [ __ ] when these
dudes out here who are really going hard
for their girl
again don't forget your crown where i go
way more in depth about how to avoid the
guys that are actually trash y'all
settling and fighting over these dudes
that make you feel like you're just a
runner-up with these other chicks
when in the beginning he was telling you
that you was the baddest you was the
realest she was the best you his wifey
you as this that and the other
but then when y'all get together he gets
inconsistent and starts making you feel
like you average
and you if you ever have questions about
how a man feels about you
ask his actions that's gonna tell you
everything you need to know heal
together without hurting each other is
actually half off right now at the link
down in the caption but if a dude don't
[ __ ] with you
[ __ ] he'll ignore you he'll cuss you out
call you out your name he'll cheat on
you even put his hands on you the last
thing a dude is not going to do if he's
really into you
is make it seem to other girls like he's
still on the market even if there's no
title yet
it ain't gonna happen so if you're
dealing with confused men don't act
confused whenever he leaves you
heartbroken in your time wasted because
that's what confused men do
if you want to know the other 11 i go in
detail about that in my book don't
forget your crown so
and we forget about the third party in
this situation i'm talking about the
third party
they didn't ask for none of this [ __ ]
whether they weren't told the truth
about what was going on at home so they
had their piece disturbed and now they
all [ __ ] up and sucked into the drama
or in a situation like this a person who
was basically preyed on in their most
vulnerable state
do we ignore you know just just chewing
somebody up and spitting them out and
then licking our fingers because the
learned lessons
were so tasty again healed together
without hurting each other is available
now
at the link down in the caption when the
violations start getting blatantly
disrespectful
like flirting with other girls checking
for other girls texting other girls
you know it's time now there are times
when both of you will cross the line but
when him crossing the line starts to get
sloppy
you know that's the relationship
equivalent to waterboarding he basically
wants you so uncomfortable that you
eventually break
now some men are real enough to say if
they don't love you anymore but then you
have those pieces of [ __ ] who show up
with their actions until all your hope
is gone and possibly your trust
and your ability to love another man put
it like this if the infractions are
starting to straight up humiliate you
it's time to let him go but the truth is
and i'm saying it here now is that
derek jackson was involved with other
women cheating affair stepping out
again hill together without hurting each
other my new book is available now at
the link down in the caption
he asked me what was my suggestion for
getting his girl back
you know admittedly he had messed up
this was a this is a real woman bonafide
like keeper and he and he let her go and
now he wants me to let him know
what his next move should be and the sad
part is
all i could tell him was that it's time
to move on again healed together without
hurting each other my new book is
available now at the link down in the
caption where i go way more into detail
about this so
i've been asked quite a few times to
speak on narcissists or guys who suffer
from narcissistic personality disorder
which is i'm not gonna get too deep into
that because i talk about it in my book
don't forget your crown
if you're hearing me say any of these
things and you're thinking to yourself
there's no man on earth who exists like
that
that's a unicorn um this is unrealistic
maybe you even got some resentment
that's kind of starting to stir up for
me
just at hearing this let me just say
that may be evidence that you need
healing and i'm not trying to invalidate
you
but pain changes all of us and the only
reason why he would think these very
real examples
i'm talking about these are examples of
dudes that i know personally outside of
me take me out of it
guys that i know personally this is just
how they show up this ain't nothing to
them you know what i'm saying so if
you're looking at any of these things
and saying well that never happens to
anybody that only happens in movies
that's evidence that's one of the
indicators that you may need healing
because pain has changed you and now is
trying to protect you
from ever having that hope this is a
spiritual warfare
and if you are not prepared and you do
not know what to do you will
drown and you will be a casualty in this
war
i did not come here to play games and to
play dress-up
i came here in my battle suit
i came here on the battle ground covered
in the blood of jesus
i receive the anointing of the righteous
and i spill the blood of the enemy
you see a bonnet i see the helmet of
salvation
you see a army green shirt i see the
breastplate of righteousness
i see the belt of truth the sandals of
peace
the sword of the spirit which is the
word of god
in the shield of faith and i've come
to the battleground covered in the blood
of jesus
to proclaim victory over sin
okay by the end of december early
i mean the end of november early
december i found that i was pregnant
like i was watching the youtube clip but
two girls came to the show i think they
were sisters they had boyfriends
and they were there to ask the host what
they should do about their controlling
boyfriends
the boyfriends wouldn't let them wear
certain things wouldn't let them go
certain places if a dude is trying to
control you
that's not cute that's your cue to leave
that's your cue to run for the [ __ ]
hills before it gets worse
control that's the segway that's the
gateway drug
to abuse ladies i know sometimes when a
dude tell you like you can't do this and
you can't do that y'all be thinking that
he just being controlling but
that ain't always the case if a dude
[ __ ] with you it is some things that
he's just not gonna tolerate
oh and another thing if a dude really
loves you he ain't gonna let you come
out the house or be on social media just
any kind of way
hardly wearing no clothes or being pissy
drunk like he ain't gonna have none of
that [ __ ]
again don't forget your crown where i go
way more in depth about how to avoid the
guys that are
actually trash but we all know actions
speak louder than words
you know but i always say patterns speak
the truth my
front balcony is in the back of his
video does it have the white arches
it's the white orchid shut the [ __ ] up
those are recess
and by the way he has a book that's
called heal together without hurting
each other
question is dee how do i make a man miss
me or you know really just regret
letting me walk away or dump him all
right
my answer is the same every single time
just invest energy into yourself stop
focusing on that let it go walk away
blah blah blah right but if you have to
get something off your chest
like if you if you just have something
on your chest it's spiteful it's petty
or whatever it is that you want to call
it and you have to get it off your chest
i would rather you take that route as
opposed to seeking out revenge and if
you're going to take that route there is
a right way to do it his advice seems
sound at first hey
forget about it move on better yourself
blah blah blah
but if you petty if you petty
i'm gonna help you okay i don't know
what kind of life cause
you know it clap your hands i'm petty
you're not petty okay
what kind of life coach is like yeah be
petty and resentful
and channel your energy at getting back
to people that you want to cut out of
your life
i don't know but maybe it's your life
coach move on with your things
but you know what we like revenge
let's see how you do the second part the
second part is cutting them off because
guess what a man wants to tell himself
after the relationship is over yeah
she's still stressing she's still in
love with me
if i wanted her back i could have her
okay
this is only true for bad people i would
never want to leave somebody i used to
like or
liked right just because maybe our
relationship's not working if i'm
leaving that person i don't want them
to linger on me i don't want them to
continue having feelings for me i don't
take
pleasure in knowing that this person has
a hard time sleeping at night or is
heartbroken that doesn't make me happy
any man who's good
and feels good he's garbage and the
sooner you can get away from that
garbage
the better so i don't know why you want
to try to get back at garbage because
listen
right the longer that you start playing
with [ __ ]
the longer you're gonna smile
again heal together without hurting each
other my new book is available now at
the link down in the caption like what
if you think somebody's trash why would
you play in the trash
because maybe you like trash so i i'm
just trying to say like that's
that's definitely not true i've never
and i mean
never left a relationship thinking yo
she's still into me that's [ __ ] dope
that's
whack i would say this doesn't really
compromise the curiosity thing really
it actually probably emboldens it but
you need to be hanging with your single
friends
out in public not at the house not
eating bon bons
not none of that no netflix none of that
you need to be out and about
even if you don't do clubs make an
exception you're going to post anything
on social media
make sure other dudes are in the picture
if it's you and your three home girls so
it's for y'all you need to be four dudes
in the picture y'all need to take a
group picture
that's a that's not a life coach that's
a toxic coach
that's a that's a coach of toxicity or
vicinity
of our setting derek jackson
is to steve harvey what darth vader is
to darth sidious
he's an apprentice yes yes but he's
about to overtake the master nah that
definitely
definitely yeah darth simpious
darth simpson that's my new nickname for
derek darth
simpson yeah yeah you can't do that with
somebody who can only
excel when it's play play time i play
play
pause i never tell them to halt
stop because i drop and roll
with the truth hot
they call me in the streets sizzling
like who sizzler
my mom said what did you say say i said
i ain't trying to get no beating though
oh god damn she said
you gonna get that beating though oh
and i'm like damn i just wanted to play
play but you know what they say say
what they say never mess with mama
because today's her day date
i came for the fans who came for him
battle reps
let's go i came with some hams okay
thanksgiving
yes go we here with some lambs listen
but we ain't getting slaughtered look
hey boy
you know what time it is what time is it
play play oh
goddamn that was how that made no sense
i mean that was hot
again healed together without hurting
each other my new book is available now
at the link down in the caption
go ahead and get an asap i'll let y'all
let you all be good
[Music]
foreign